[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm and I'm link
this week at my round table of dining
and rets I can't actually see your table
from my my green same table as last time
I've got the square original the classic
original rattling table
yes but hey I've switched rooms man as
you can see I am in front of my own skin
whoo yeah you are you're halfway and
you're halfway skinned halfway on ski I
I came in here because I thought there
might be better acoustics I don't know
if there is I think you're still pretty
there's a rug there's also a child's bed
which I came in here I was like yeah
there's a single leg has put H I'll call
it a child's bed it is a child's bed it
is a white bed that has drawers there on
the side of it yes every characteristic
about this bed as a child's but it's a
single bed and yeah it's got drawers
underneath it's an Ikea bed that that's
kind of a vibe killer it's high tide
just got to be honest with you I never
vibe yeah well it was in my garage and
it's kind of a garage killer and I'm
like you know what what I'm fetching
that creative house we could use a bed
that is the bed that when Britain lived
in my closet for over a year I call it a
closet but it was just like a an office
a very small office it barely fit that
single bed and annoyed barely fit
Britain I slept in a single bed until I
got married all the way through Cowell I
slept in a single day was extra extra
long actually I sleep in this bed I mean
I could I guess I could sleep on my side
but I mean I just not that we have done
anything over here done anything over
there it's just a bed right like I know
but it could be like a cool couch that
you could also sleep on it like a bit of
child's bed
Abed I mean we don't need a bed it was
laid in my garage so I put the bed over
there have you laid on there let's sell
it it's an it's got a nice mattress on
it it's nice I laid on it I just moved
it because it was right here and you
know oh you moved it to the other side
that's right cuz this it was up against
my skin wall you bedded my skin wall
well I wouldn't put it in those terms we
talked about are going in an effort to
continue to have a sense of connection
amidst such isolation we asked you your
biscuit ear to set up some topics of
conversations some questions that we
could discuss between the two of us and
we've got some we've got some good
conversation starters here we got some
good questions from you guys you want to
get into the first one what do we did
you give the prompt or we just I mean it
kind of gave a version of the probs I
didn't I don't I don't remember what the
prompt was honestly I think it was
you've been in isolation
yeah or you've had one time to think
about things what have you been thinking
about alone that we could talk about
together correct answers she says if he
had an opportunity to go back and relive
a part of your life would you by doing
so just to clarify she says it wouldn't
change the present you would do it more
to relive an amazing experience or event
that you forget if so what part of your
life would you choose now I I love
questions that don't have consequences
because you know I'm sure in the past
we've talked about like time travel or
like what we definitely taught about
points in in our past that we've
experienced but we've definitely thought
about points at our past there yeah
that's kind of our entire existence but
I think maybe we've talked about
reliving stuff but I always get wigged
out about is it going what are the
ramifications
you know yeah the fact they solicited a
movie out yeah so first of all I mean I
think that for me immediately when you
add the qualifier of you won't change it
well of course if I had the option to
just go back and relive one moment of
course I'm gonna do it but have to
choose one moment yeah I know it's like
you have something in mind cuz I'm
having difficulty Mehran yeah yeah I do
have something and you you might think
that it would you know some of the
typical answers that come to mind are
things like well at the very first
moment I met my wife or my wedding day
or the birth of my kids one of the have
to choose one and while all those would
be candidates for me I feel like I don't
feel like in the moment that those
things were happening and this may be a
reason to go back to them I don't feel
like I was thinking the right things in
those moments and are like really like
experiencing them in the right way but
when I did start thinking about a moment
where in the moment I said to myself
this is as good as it gets I have a
candidate okay you were there you were
there but you weren't you were you were
tangentially there hmm
we were should I guess oh you're surfing
okay I know and I think I know what
you're going at I call and I caught a
wave and a dolphin caught the waves with
me yeah and I was there surfing with me
and you told me afterward did you see
that and I was like yeah saw you catch
the wave it was great and you said there
was a dolphin in the wave and I did not
see that so can I go back and see the
dolphin well I mean you should probably
have your own that doesn't involve
watching me do so when you go back
I'll be there so I want you to say on
this next wave look for dolphins in the
wave and then as and then in the future
which is now as we're having this
conversation my answer might be remember
that time that I saw that dolphin in the
way and I swam over to it and you were
riding the wave and I was riding the
dolphin well but here's the thing
do you by doing that you would change
you said you wouldn't change it you
would change the moment if you try to
ride the dolphin because I was riding
the wave and it was like you know we
hadn't been surfing that long like
catching a wave and like really catching
a wave was still a big deal and it was
it was one of those days where it was
just a low long slow strong wave so you
had time to like think and experience it
you know and then I look down and
there's a freaking the smartest mammal
in the ocean besides me she is is just
sitting there just hovering in the water
next to me going the same speed and I
was like it can't get any better than
this you know what your life just peaked
if it was if it was nighttime and you
were surfing on one of those waves and
dolphin was in it but it was one of
those iridescent glowing waves that's
happening off the coast of California
right now like there's people is still
happening and you know I don't know if
it still happening but I think it was a
was short window as of like within the
past week it was happening and hmm I
wanted to drive and see that but I have
not done that but of course they're
opening they've opened the California
beaches for you can't sunbathe but you
can surf and you can jog you can do like
activities and guess who bought a new
surfboard you did your buddy
you bought a new surfboard I bought
haven't even been using the money you
got I bought a regular surfboard I
bought an 11 foot longboard because
I'm going I have to I have to do regular
surfing man I have to look I have to get
where I don't have to have the paddle
because I want to be able to go to like
Malibu and surf without people looking
at me like I'm a dork I have to do that
I have to get to that place yeah I made
up my mind so what are you gonna do you
know I start you gonna start serving you
gonna ask me to go and then I'm gonna be
out there on a paddleboard you didn't
you didn't even include me in this now
you go out there you're gonna be that
guy with the paddleboard
well the places that we typically go
there's a lot of people with paddle
boards and there's also people who go
out one person's on a paddle board and
like somebody else is not on a paddle
board I think that's fine it's just if I
get where I'm good and then I'm like hey
man I'm going to Malibu at that point
you have to make a decision and by the
way I have never been kind of late well
you told me that you can't paddle
because of your shoulder so I don't know
what to do about that I think that's it
yeah I just I don't know what I've been
practicing I've been practicing my
pop-ups I've been just out in the yard
just just popping up
so you you ordered a surfboard and it
was delivered to your house a big honkin
surfboard at 11 feet yes very really
really long but very very big man you
probably paddleboard it is not even that
long
no it's longer it's longer or at the
same length as my existing paddleboard
but it's much narrower well I definitely
miss going surfing and now they've
opened up the surf so you can go surfing
I was gonna tell you next chance we get
we should go and I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go on my existing paddleboard the thing
that I probably have lost the ability to
do because it's been so long since we
been but I'll probably pick it up faster
than you will trying to top on one of
those non paddle boards here here's the
thing he's gonna wait if you just take
off with it then I'm gonna be tempted
I'm gonna be tempted to try it I don't
want to be left to it and it's not like
I didn't get like a I still got a soft
top I didn't get like a
I mean I got like a surf tech is that
like a Walmart brand or something no
it's like the kind you learn on ok no I
it's still very and not in not
intimidating and like if I hit somebody
with the board they're not gonna die you
can yeah
but eventually I will get a board that I
could kill people with my dad told me
that we moved to California when I was
three years old I remember not at three
but like at five my dad was talking
about the surfers at Malibu he was like
you realized that if you go out there
and you get in the way of the surfers
they'll they have really sharp boards
and they'll shoot the board into your
head and kill you on purpose on purpose
mm-hm as opposed to on talk about a
surrogate or what I would be I went back
to relive that memory that you okay that
you picked that see cuz my mind
immediately went to things in my in my
past that were extremely meaningful
experiences that I don't think I
approached it correctly which you
alluded to so yeah I'm too worried about
that I'm too worried about going back
and I don't know so I picked a moment
where I felt like I did appreciate it in
the moment so that I could just go back
and do it exactly the same way again I
that's what that's what struck me but I
get what you're what you're saying yeah
I and that is why the first thing that
popped into my head was my wedding day
because I think it would first of all I
know that I didn't enjoy myself I was I
was like it I was like a nervous wreck
the night before at the rehearsal dinner
I was a nervous wreck you know we've
been through this and you know I just I
tried when I think back on that I try to
apply that to my life now but it's so
hard to be in a moment saying you know
what I'm gonna enjoy this moment because
what whatever it is it concerns you
about it and with the wedding day I
can't even tell you everything I was
concerned about it was just everyone
else's expectations which is totally
wrong it's this is it's my day and Chris
de-what why on earth am I so concerned
about everyone else's experience and
everything like that you know I would
totally have them soaking in and have a
much better time I would also get really
get a kick out of because everybody that
we both knew pretty much was in
attendance so it would be a weighted to
to rub elbows with everybody and have I
mean I had a moment with everybody at
like the wedding reception and but
that's like I don't even remember it was
such a blur so I think it's it's like a
cheat code to have to have one moment in
time or have access to everyone up until
that point in my life that was
meaningful
I had a meaningful relationship with was
there from my past and that my then
present you know so I think I think I
packed it with that one I think that's
actually I think and the fact that you
couldn't change anything so then you
could go back and it is it wouldn't just
be about savoring and enjoying it you
could also be like what if I did this
like Groundhog Day there are no
consequences what if I just drop my
pants in the middle of my wedding like
wouldn't it be fun to see how
everybody's really that I didn't drop my
pants during my wedding serum no but if
there were no consequences wouldn't you
just do something to stir it up I my
hesitancy to in choosing a moment like
that was i if I go back too far I think
I would just be thinking about things
like well my body feels different you
know what I'm saying whereas going back
to surfing like three years ago pretty
much the same guy like I I wouldn't be
thinking like man like I feel so spry
right now I'm gonna run or you know it
would have increased our frequency of
surfing the chances of that happening
again aren't it's not out of the
question you know oh I know surfing with
surfing with dolphins is actually yeah
it's it's something that happens so you
could happen again yeah it but I'm not
getting married again all the time of
course I'll be out there on a
paddleboard and like I'll be able to go
with the pod and you'll be just
you'll be you'll be all alone I am
worried about figuring out shape enough
it's it wears you out yeah I just don't
my shoulders and just like upper body
strength like I don't have any chest
muscles but I don't think you need I
don't think you need when I winced when
I went to my therapist guru you know in
addition to all the things that I told
you that she told me about inviting my
weird rib to the party how's that going
is he glad to the party yet I don't I
can touch it now a little bit
touching it right now but it still
freaks me out she the first thing she
did was she said you don't have any you
chest muscles she basically told me I
had a bird chest and I paid her for that
right you know I was paying her some
people pay for insults it's a thing I
think it's like good as an ending I
would go all right so I guess that's my
answer I would go back to that physical
therapy appointment so I could that was
a wild ride man I mean I miss my
physical I noticed everything about my
life that was weird you know that I
don't get to go out and do like be
critiqued by my physical therapist or go
surfing but you know and we'll move on
in a second but the real thing that got
me going on this getting a regular
surfboard
first of all I had like a foam board
that is not I went out at that one time
I'm just I'm too big for it like it's
not rated for it was ready for like 200
pounds I weighed like 220 I needed like
a legit board that'll hold me up but the
thing I was thinking is that we've got
these ideas we've been talking about
weird like we've got some surfing
related ideas that I actually want to
get serious about and they require like
actually regular surfing and not not
having your hands on a paddle and so I
was like I just gotta learn how to do
this well thanks for the heads up is all
I'm saying
I mean I would you have gone out you
wouldn't gone out and bought a board
you would you would have said well let's
see how you do with yours so that's why
I haven't told you about every all right
next up it go here we are I'll just take
my board out and then eventually I'll
get good and you'll be like man you
don't even have a paddle
it'll be like yeah you can you can have
for this - hmm
are you gonna let me try it yeah yeah I
might I might have some hidden hidden
ability do it all of a sudden since last
time we did it it's all about we got to
get in better shape it's all about
endurance that's the only that's it
that's the x-factor you just got to have
the ability because out there no way you
still have energy to stand up when to
exude exert yourself it but once you
understand how to do something then you
can channel your exertion and not waste
a bunch of energy doing all the wrong
things you know that's true with any
type of physical thing you know I'm an
athlete I don't stand these principles
and I and I actually have been watching
youtube videos about and we did so many
things wrong with that that day we went
out with regular boards so many things
wrong Oh tell me yeah things wrong okay
yeah I'll show you the YouTube videos I
can benefit from that we got another
question about music I'm excited about
but first let's promote some merch
check it we would bring him back the
mythical the mythical we're associating
mythical with the clown shark in a shirt
well yeah speaking of the creatures
which is you know it's interesting
that's one of the things that Locke said
about surfing because I was like hey you
know maybe later this summer since the
beaches are open and now I've got these
I've got two other foam boards that are
like smaller I was like hey me and you
and Shepherd could go we could do some
surfing together he's like dad sharks
it's like I'm really scared of sharks
and oh yeah I'll be honest with you you
think about it a lot and there was at
one time in Santa Cruz where I served a
little bit that summer and there was a
guy watching a surf and then when it was
big group of people you know Santa Cruz
and then when we got out he was like
yeah you know there was a great white
circling all of you the whole time you
were surfing
because you can see from the cliff
did you believe so it does happen I heat
prep yeah I mean it does happen but they
don't they very rarely attack man
they're just there's clowns they don't
escape on your shirt
mythical calm check out all the stuff we
got over there you'd be surprised if you
haven't if you haven't checked it out in
a while look at our store mythic or not
can be surprised rip you boy mythical
calm you'd be surprised
tea up another okay JT one why is the
music of the 70s 80s and 90s so good is
it just nostalgia or is it because music
was truly epically good then and now
it's just not as good / harder to find
good music oftentimes the music now is
good that is good has strong influence
from the 70s 80s or 90s hmm well first
of all I agree to the 70s and 80s are
good in terms of music now 90s I feel
like you got to be more specific in
order to say it's good I don't think
everything in the 90's is good and I
think that kind of gets at where I
ultimately I'm gonna pick apart JT with
an A in an e stale that's so my
interpretation if I agree with you and I
think the reason for that perspective
which a lot of people have there's I've
got two thoughts on this the first is
the further you get away from a time
period the more it crystallizes ya in
your nestling you're not hearing the
like only what's worthy of sticking
around has stuck around so when you
think of that decade you only think
about the stuff that's stood the test it
has staying power yeah so it's not that
the 70s or the 80s I mean well first of
all it probably did have less music and
there is more
which is a factor there's a more music
because it's easier and easier to make
music independently than it was back in
the day so as time has passed there's
just more and more music so I guess it's
more it's easier for something to stand
out but it isn't like there wasn't a lot
of different music happening in the 70s
or the 80s it's just not all of that
stuck stuck stuck around and we're close
we're still pretty close to the 90s like
you know people like us
that way we're in high school we're in
college at that time yeah I'll make a
tangential statement which I think might
be controversial or at least people who
disagree with it I think that hip-hop
now is better than it's ever been
period so to me this is an exception
this is this isn't this is my personal
exception to this is that it's the best
that's ever been I mean when you go back
and listen to it when you listen to
hip-hop
it's very especially like early hip-hop
I'm talking like a bluesy yeah I mean if
you go back to the inception it's very
exciting to listen to from a nostalgic
standpoint because it was just starting
to bud and now it's blossomed into all
different all different genres and it
changes so fast it makes use of every it
seems like every everything that catches
leads to the next thing and benefits
from it I mean I I love music for a
number of reasons but I love that aspect
of it when when JT was talking about the
strong influence of the 70s 80s and 90s
or basically you're dissing music
influences music influences music and it
moves forward but I just feel like now
there's so much to enjoy and there's so
many subgenres of hip-hop that early on
like classic you just didn't you know it
was still forming and it's
and so there's there's more to enjoy
it's it's it's better now especially
because it's the whole conceit of
hip-hop from a production standpoint is
taking things and then repurposing and
remaking them you know between sampling
and splicing and looping and all of that
I just think it's better well okay I
have but the second part of my thought
actually ties into what you're talking
about and I'm gonna use the MBA as an
analogy right and we both been watching
the last dance which I hope that wasn't
gonna be your wreck we can talk it was
it could we can tease erect so if you
care about sports and based on the
couple of times I've said things about
sports on Twitter I get the impression
that the mythical beast heard is not not
a lot of sports fans but there are some
but this last dance ESPN documentary
about the Bulls Chicago Bulls and
Michael Jordan is phenomenal is one of
the best things I've ever watched in
entertainment period if you're into
basketball as your age so if you can if
you lived through those seasons in the
yeah that was what 98 97 I won again
they go through the basically go through
Jordan's career but they don't really
focus on the 97 98 season now one of the
things that comes up a lot of times is
this you know hypothetical conversation
about how good would Jordan be now and
this is one of the you know you're
watching it with Lincoln I watch it with
Locke and so we're watching it with
these teenage boys who are really into
basketball love the NBA you know Locke
kept leaning over during this thing he's
like I just didn't know he was that good
I just I didn't appreciate how good
Jordan was yeah now but then when you
ask the hypothetical question
well how would Jordan be if you just
took him literally you took 1995 Michael
Jordan now you just put him on an NBA
court now you know that's it he just
he's there and how would he do and I
feel pretty strongly that he would just
be sort of a middle-of-the-road player
initially now I think that he would
adjust pretty quickly and become one of
the he would become an all-star most
likely but it's not a cut and dry
situation now the reason I say that is
and you actually get this when you watch
the documentary you know Jordan wasn't
playing basketball in the offseason he
didn't even start lifting weights until
he'd lost to the Pistons two years in a
row
yeah and was pissed off about it piston
yeah the system that generates
basketball players now is a completely
different system that has been
fine-tuned you know he was he didn't
even make his varsity this story goes
you know in that they talked about the
documentary he didn't make his varsity
team is sophomore year but now kids who
are going to be and you look at the
other bulls like Scottie Pippen going to
like Central Arkansas or whatever and
then like Horace Grant went to some
other school that nobody small school
that doesn't happen anymore because the
system that who creates these NBA
players at that level their nutrition
their fitness their practice their
insights that they get their coaching
everything has been fine-tuned and it is
it is definitively better now you might
be like it's not as rough or whatever
but if you were to take a look bran as
developed as he is and you just throw
him back into that system I think he
would dominate even more than he does
because of the system he's come up in
now I think the same holds true in music
and what your but I think there's
something special about that time
because one of the things that makes it
so special is that the opportunity to
innovate and stand above the competition
and the way that Jordan did is something
that is so hard to do
there's not gonna be another Michael
Jordan because the Delta on the
opportunity for innovation is smaller
than it's ever been because the system
is so efficient at producing excellence
right and so I think the same thing has
happened in music and also the
accessibility for people to create music
on their own has gotten where we are
just overwhelmed with really I mean it
there's there's a lot of good music
there's also a lot of bad music because
there's so much opportunity and I just
think we've gotten to a place where
finding the special connection with
music is harder to do than it was at
that point and it doesn't mean that it's
not good or better or the music was but
the music was let's just say more
special back when the threshold or the
threshold to the barrier to entry to
actually make music was bigger yeah
that's my add to my theory okay well
there's there's two parts of that I mean
I think I agree that the fact that
there's so many more artists who can be
heard that it's it's it's hard for any
one artist to really pop I mean of
course it still happens I mean you've
got superstars
you've got your Lady Gaga's you got your
Drake's but it but it doesn't feel
different than back in the era of
Michael Jackson yeah because there's
still your there's still so much
competition
I mean Drake can't go away that long
he's you know he's got his features have
to be just as groundbreaking as his own
albums or mixtapes and you know it has
to keep coming in order to remain
relevant you just can't you've got to
work really hard for that because
there's so much competition the part
about the system though I I don't I
don't I think the analogy doesn't work
there I mean if you look at if you just
look at country music and how the
Nashville sound came about and there was
a hole there was a manufacturing process
around around that around the early days
of rock and roll I mean you got the you
know you've got Glen Campbell and the
the names leaving me at this point but
like that the supergroup of studio
musicians who are just creating this
journey they just they show up every day
and churn out these tracks for for some
for some singer-songwriter or somebody
who's a pretty face or a pretty voice so
there there was a machine for what it
was a machine based but it was a machine
based on pure talent like Glen Campbell
is sitting there like physically
interacting with a sonic instrument to
make noise whereas now a 12 year old is
in his room with GarageBand and creates
something and it's just like if I was
talking about the Wrecking Crew
the Los Angeles studio based crew that
brought in that's not country music but
they don't but don't you think that
that's I guess what I'm saying is and
maybe this does go against my analogy I
think that that the Wrecking Crew was
doing something that's more special than
the 12 year old in their room with
GarageBand well yeah I gotta say no but
it's not see 'some but I'm just saying
it's not it isn't as special because how
many wrecking crews can there be well
there's only a limited number of how
many there could be they turn into all
girls to get GarageBand yes but again I
think it's a but there are still people
who are making them amazing music using
those tools and there's there's a lot
more opportunity for true artists to to
come out of the woodwork and I and I
think that they're you know I think it
but I was so close to it you know I
think time will tell time will tell if
are we gonna be listening to my strange
addiction you know 20 years from now
probably III think that the things the
simple fact that there's it's so clouded
with so many more options over time and
because of the revolution of digital
music digital music that replicates
analog music I feel like you're gonna
look back and it's gonna be much more
difficult to recognize the sound of a
decade I think that the recognizing the
sound of a decade is something that
potentially died in the 90s I don't know
I don't know if it made it into the new
millennium I just think I just think
we're too close to it I mean some
difference between that set the set what
is the sound of the 2000s versus the
sound of the 2010s what's three or two
decades what's the difference between
the last Justin Timberlake album which
maybe is a bad example because I didn't
listen to it versus the the last NSYNC
album a whole lot you know I think he
was wearing like a flannel on the cover
of that album I was like say something
about the woods I mean I didn't listen
to that one so I don't know but um well
you're right time will tell I'm just
saying that my theory at this point is
that it won't there won't be a
definitive like when you think 50s music
what do you think you think like doo-wop
right not as good you know when you
think sixties music you think I like
late starting to get into some low okay
weird
hippies late late 60s you get it gets
real good yeah that's what music started
to get real good but it wasn't before I
mean in my opinion it wasn't before then
but then there's always something that's
gonna grip you since then there's a limb
but it's really splintered and I think
that just to wrap it up I think that
most of what grabs me is the stuff that
is calling back to the times where I
thought that music was special so there
for me there's not a whole lot of music
that's being made that it
isn't really heavily influenced by
something in the past that I'm really
into like I'm not into any new genres no
I think that but the phrase influenced
by the past yeah why do you have to say
that it's like that okay well no no what
I'm saying is it's like everything's
influenced by something all music is
influenced by something so I don't but
some things are some things are more of
a departure from the past than others
some things call back more thoroughly so
in other words like I'm not I'm not an
EDM fan because it's very difficult for
EDM to capture much of anything from the
past because it's a very future
futuristic forward-looking genre but I
just don't there's no soul in it to me I
don't I don't connect with it but that
seems I was wrong with me
yeah I mean in it but do you can I you
like EDM I don't know and no and I don't
know enough about it I'm but I'm not
gonna say that it's not influenced by
stuff because it absolutely has to it's
clearly influenced by stuff but it's but
it's a more bold departure than say
Jason Isbell you don't know Zayin I
don't know no like I mean I haven't
listened to a lot of craft work either
but it's like I mean what is that craft
work I think had to influence all
electronic music from the 70s what is
craft work craft work is um craft work
with a K and then an E is it a band is
that what you're saying yeah German band
formed in 1970 widely considers
innovators and pioneers of electronic
music they were among the first
successful acts to popularize the genre
it's just you're not in electronic music
no but yeah I mean you'll like the Daft
Punk album just like I will but it's
just not your thing but when it's not
our thing
and why do I like the Dethklok album
because it's a it is by definition a
strong throw back to the 70s in disco
and even has it even has the story of
the connection to the original pioneers
of disco in the album built into the
album they tell the story
so it from in that connects back to a
time when I was actually alive I was a
little I don't live baby I don't think
that's what the story is I think it's
the inventor of the synthesizer I'm just
saying it's a different thing we don't
know as much but he talks about that he
talks about that beat the click track
and stuff I'm just saying that like it's
literally a throwback and it's got its
got a historical angle and that's why we
like it but if things get too on the
cutting edge of the future we don't like
it anymore and unless you're really
really hip and I don't want to be that
hip I'm not that dad I don't know I
think about we could have we could have
easily made this into an episode by the
way and we just made it into one
question so maybe we'll have to come
back to well I know it for for the next
listening party Britt and I are working
we were like we got to do something we
got to do some music that's now so I
think by the time this comes out it
would have come out but we decided we
were only gonna play music for each
other that is music that's moving us now
like brand-new music I cover the weeks
or months old and I had to get excited
about it in a different way because it
was more simple to get excited about but
I but there's lots of music that's
moving me sick can happen yeah I mean
that yeah I I agree let's move on to
another question
this one's from Rafa Conrad what is your
perspective about fandoms okay it's it's
interesting because I've been thinking
more about more about fandoms lately
because and I think this is true for you
too I'll just speak for myself I I
wouldn't consider myself I've never
experienced being a part of a fandom
now obviously I'm excluding the fact
that you know that we there's a fandom
around what we do there's a mythical
fandom I'm very grateful for that
I'm very reverent towards what how how
people are have created it as a fandom
but it is it it's I observe it from the
I don't want to say from the top down or
from the outside am but like I mean a
fan I'm formed around the stuff that we
create but I don't even though I'm very
passionate about a lot of things I don't
think that I could say that I've ever
actually been a part of a fandom and
I'll I will tease that I gained some
insight through some recent experiences
what I'll talk about in a second but I
just wanted to put that out there at
first have we have either one of us ever
been a part of a fandom and how do we
define fandom do we need to look that up
like Kraftwerk I mean you can look it up
but I'll give you my lamest definition
you can see if google agrees with me
yeah I think it's it's a group of people
who have connected with each other
because they have connected with all
connected together around something else
that they like yeah fans of a particular
person team fictional series etc
regarded collectively as a community or
subculture so yeah I know yeah I would
yeah I think that for me the community
aspect is the thing so I would consider
I'm probably I'm the most time a part of
a fandom is a fan of NC State athletics
I mean that that's the easiest thing
right so my college links college so it
isn't like I have a group of people that
I get together with and watch games but
I have like you know a couple of our
college buddies that I'll talk to about
big game or something like that I mean
there are there's like a group of NC
State people that get together it like a
bar and Pasadena and watch really watch
games together you I've thought about it
I don't think I'm gonna do it but I have
thought about it because you know
especially when the thing about being a
part of a fandom
that you relate in this way and when
you're an NC State sports fan you relate
in a very particular way of like having
your hopes dashed against the rocks of
yeah reality over and over again for
decades and decades and that makes you a
certain type of fan right and so there's
a connection there just a like
mindedness that you don't even have to
think about when you meet somebody oh
and if you see somebody with an in sees
like the thing is is that like the the
block s from Stanford is exactly the
same as the block cast from NC State
except the NC State has in NC kind of
small in there and so usually I when I
first moved down here I saw these block
s's and I was like state no Stanford
state in the state you never see
somebody wearing and he thinks NC State
but until you do maybe five in ten years
and I talked to these people yeah but I
don't do because there's so much stuff
Lee anybody it's busy like in medieval
times if you got if you get thrown in
the dungeon you're like in the blocks
and you're like you're in the shackles
what are you gonna do you're gonna start
you gonna start talking to the guy or
the gal next to you you know you're
gonna hey you're gonna you're gonna
connect in the misery of being in that
situation that's what it's like to be a
Wolfpack fan and so look if you're gonna
endure the heart-wrenching and you've
opted to box it out by involved it out
of that I've opted out I mean I love I
love NC State I love my experience but I
just cannot when it comes to the the
sports experience I cannot stand being
being trampled and then getting my hopes
up just enough to think that it's not
gonna happen
the time after or the time after that
yeah I get it
but so so yeah there's a you have this
need for connection I mean my my insight
came when and you know I was talking
about how Lily and I started watching
John Mayer's live Instagram show called
current mood which is roughly comes out
every week you know we're both
fans of his music our families are big
fans of his music you know we're
middle-aged white guys what are we
supposed to do but you got a Ledge on
there but like our entry card if you
don't like John Mayer Lily Lily's really
into it and she got me into current mood
and I've it was such a different
experience because well it was live so
there was like more of a connect we've
done a lot of live stuff and we really
built we really started to build our
community when we were doing that rhett
and Link that's live there is something
magical about knowing that this is
happening now and if I type something he
might he might read it he might respond
to it there could be a little
conversation some acknowledgement but
even beyond that when when an episode
was over and I was reflecting on it I
just started to appreciate specifics
about it like why I was really into it
you know the fact that he has a certain
sense of humor but he also talked about
things that are serious and he processes
things in an interesting way and he
thinks in a similar way to me I started
to relate on that level and I started to
become curious how many other people had
that type of experience and Here I am in
bed I'm on Reddit anyway I might I put
two there's a John Mayer reddit thread I
wonder if there's a current mood reddit
thread because I didn't want to just
talk about I didn't want to be a fan of
John Mayer I wanted to talk about the SH
that show specifically and like the
episode I just watched I fellas I've
wanted to discuss it with other people
and there there wasn't one
there was a John Mayer read it some
people have talked about sure that you
were gonna say that there was so I
actually found that I was frustrated
that there wasn't and I ain't gonna
started I ain't got time for that but
sometimes there's a current mood entry
in the John Mayer thread and I don't
even know what John Mayer fans are
called if they have a name like how they
associate themselves in the fandom but
again I'm speaking of it as if I'm not
involved in it but I'm
I've gotten as close as I as I have to
saying that I'm in a fandom because I
found myself wanting to just talk to
people about somebody else's work and
connect over it and I don't think I mean
I really like connecting and talking to
people about music and but music is not
a fandom you know it's got to be a
specific thing and you'd actually get
started
hold on you mean when you put on your
dating profile that you like music that
doesn't mean anything right right yeah
and for the record I do not have a
dating profile so right I don't know
what rich was right to but if you did
you wouldn't say I'm really into music I
would put I would I would I would put
I'm I like listening to music that's a
hobby of mine but when when I say that I
really mean it like I like to sit down
and listen to music and I like to think
about it and I like to talk about it so
I'm not some I'm not just somebody who
says yeah I like music y'all like I like
food I'm like eat saying I like this
music is like I like food where I like
sunshine but I started to think I gained
insight into how the mythical beasts
enjoy our content because there's it
when you really get something and I feel
like you know the mythical beasts really
get us I think that's what that's what
it means to be a mythical beast that you
watch it and you you understand why it's
what they want to connect to us we don't
make them they connect to who we are and
I started doing this yes
somebody likes a cheap life then you
like yeah because we taught about Merle
Haggard and I think that right the the
thing that the thing that we didn't do
me and you connected with each other
right over our love for Merle but we
didn't connect with a greater fandom
because when we went to the concerts it
was a bunch of 65 year old people right
and I'm not Britain you know what I'm
saying like your cousin Brittany will go
Stu a [ __ ]
convention and comeback best friends
with a 94 year old woman it's like you
know and that's awesome and I wish I was
more open to personal connection than
that but I just I'm not so it was like
oh my friend likes this this is
something we connect but the greater
community of people who would call
themselves mayor heads or whatever
mayor's
maybe there's call themselves mayors if
they're all mayors of mayor town john
mayer fans i don't know it to some
extent it feels like a commitment it's
the same reason I don't go I consider
myself an NC State sports fan but I
don't go to that bar to watch and see
State lose in sports with other people
because you got to commute you got to
commit you got to commit not just to the
thing that you like you have to commit
to the other people who like it yeah
there's a lot more time involved and I
think I found myself if there was a John
Mayer if there was a current mood
discussion like that was reliable every
week like I in this environment right
now being home so much like I could see
myself starting to make friends in that
environment and start you know it's you
know Mike our friend science Mike he's
big into Dungeons and Dragons he talks
to us about it but he talks about how
he'll play and he has a group of friends
that he plays with that some of them
were were were members of his community
who also like Dungeons and Dragons were
part of that community so then they
would form their own little group but I
mean I mean you got the whole tricky
thing that was the the quintessential
beginning of condoms in my mind when you
go to a convention and then you would be
make friends with those people and that
was but I think in this environment and
by the way but by cohn I did not mean
the Wrath of Khan I just met conventions
yes you did but there is a double
meaning and you have to specify when
you're talking about Star Trek or Star
Trek as I said until I was like 13 but I
don't know I don't know maybe I need to
go full in on a fandom in order to then
be a better
what are we figure heads of the mythical
fandom figure it if someone really
doesn't do anything but well kind of
there's a there's a being careful with
that there's a very specific opportunity
given the fact that there's two of us
because you could become part of my
fandom and I could become part of your
fandom and that's how we fully
participate in the mythical fandom is
just like hey I'm a big fan of the
mythical mythical stuff but really it's
you're gonna start tweeting the night
you're gonna start tweeting oh yeah you
know when link said so and so so it's
like one that wasn't that cool I'm gonna
I'm gonna start like a I'm gonna start a
Twitter account this light links ocean
blue eyes or something like that and
tweet about you constantly that's what
I'm gonna do what do you have what you
gonna do about me I'm already I'm
already really close to being an Mayer
head I think that's where I want to go
well I'm not committed to you if you
don't commit to me
we have enough commitments to each other
we don't need to be each other's biggest
fan okay let's let's do it let's do one
more question all right this one's from
Michelle very practical thoughts about
using a blanket on the couch does it
need to be folded or put away after each
use even if you know you're going to
just pull it out next time my husband
says yes but I say no I literally use a
blanket on the couch year-round we use
the blanket on the couch year-round
I mean there's certain blankets that our
entire family has
they considered the best blanket and so
then we bought a weighted blanket and
for a little bit the weighted blanket
became the coveted blanket everyone
fought over you had to get on there you
had to get underneath it first as like
calling shotgun but then turns out the
weighted blanket was too heavy too
weighted so now the second most popular
blanket has now become the most
preferred again for most people it gets
too warm and it's and you can injure
yourself moving it I don't like the way
to blanket because I could hurt my
shoulders trying to pick that thing up
and moving
I got to deserve that for surfing how
did you hurt yourself well I tried to
move a weighted blanket so our second
most popular blanket became the coveted
blanket it again I'm looking at it over
there and it's gone somebody's got it
and we just bought a second one we sure
bought five of them so I will say
there's always blanket you watch a movie
together when you watch a movie together
everyone has a blanket all five yeah
pretty yeah yes interesting because when
we watch a movie together they all have
blankets and I just I don't I just don't
quite get it I'm kind of are you warm
natured you're low warm natured no I'm
actually I get cold most the time when
you say that you're cold I'm like what I
think about I'm like yeah he's a little
cold I just honestly should get a blank
I don't I don't think about it as much
and I like a blanket I think it's just I
just assumed that it's not going to be
big enough I just assumed that all
blankets don't won't fit me and so I
just it's like it's the reason I don't
try things on it stores of ice not gonna
fit me our favorite blanket is big
enough for you man it's such a big
blanket you can I take that blanket and
I can I can hold it it's it's about it's
like a six by eight blanket that would
fit me now but we do so we have a lot of
blankets you know on the couch well with
there's at least two for some reason
there's usually two and since three of
them won't blankets they get in fights
and I don't know why we haven't done
them
on this but my wife is cleaning up
constantly and the rest of us are my
kids significantly worse than me
creating mess yeah right
and it's interesting now given
quarantine because we don't have anybody
over right so Jesse likes to get the
house real nice for people who don't
live in it yeah you know and but we've
been keeping it pretty clean but I gotta
say that the blankets have just been
nonchalantly thrown over the couch and
sort of left in place for I'd say weeks
now with no like there's no folding and
putting away you know if she gets into a
cleaning mindset they will be folded and
put away only to be taken out again even
in this environment I think that creates
a lot of problems I mean you can
anticipate my position on this I think
that blankets should be folded and not
put away what they should be fooling
problems when you walk up to a couch and
there's a blanket that someone's been in
on it and it's like just like a clump of
blanket but floating doesn't make it
cleaner it is not inviting because it
says someone else has been in this
someone else's body's body smells and
skin cells and stuff is is all in it now
if you fold it up that statement still
true but it doesn't idiot more so it
doesn't make you think about it it
doesn't but logically if you think is
blanket but the other parts of the
person that came off of them and got on
the blanket are now folded up and
they're multiplying when it's full
they're not at least when it's out in
the open it's they're dying it's not
Lisa's in a clump it's like a brain it's
smushed together and there's alt is even
more crevices there's even more good
things the viruses that are on the
people are being crushed by the blanket
being folded not true I'm talking about
the viruses at all I just think it is
not invited
to go into like if a shirts hanging on a
rack you're like I could try that on
if the shirts laying in the bottom of a
you know the the stall I don't want to
try that on even though someone else has
already tried on both of those shirts to
use your okay let me ask you a different
question that's related to this when
your wife goes out of town and you're at
home alone do you make the bed and why I
like to make the bed because then if I
if I take a nap I like to take a nap on
top of the bed because if I get under
the covers and that's not a nap that's
sleeping well I was trying to trap you
because your logic of other people's
parts doesn't apply when it's just you
sleeping in a bed right I just think the
part it's just more exciting when you
walk in a room and there's like there's
a blanket here and it's folded there's a
blanket draped over here strategically
it's like oh and then it also it's ended
when something's in clumps it sends a
signal to the other people in the house
the kids that you know what oh I can
leave my chip bag here I can leave my
half drunk can a la croix here I can
leave my home with a clean bed yeah
listen
Saotome I don't agree and as you might
guess I do not make the bed what I'm
sleeping alone in it and my wife makes
the bed literally [ __ ] like the like she
can't start her life if the bed isn't
made and every single time I don't make
the bed every morning but I do like and
may bed but every single time I'm
participating in the making of the bed
because if I happen to get caught in the
room at the time when she's doing it
I got long arms I look like I'm made to
make beds yeah I have to help I get
recruited and
every single time I'm doing it I have a
number of thoughts I'm flooded with
thoughts one of them is there's got to
be a better system like
there's got to be something that is
closer to a sleeping bag you know what
I'm saying like I just just the multiple
sheets and the way things have to fold
down and and don't get me started on a
freaking down comforter I'm sure your
wife has the same thing our wives
getting similar things but it's this
down comforter that has a do a duvet
cover and then you have to pull it in
and then if we didn't fold it backwards
and like tie it and a certain when we
start doing that I start going ballistic
every single time I'm just like I don't
understand why is this the system this
has been around for who knows how many
hundreds of years and this is the way
we're still doing it I would gladly make
the bed if it was like Jetsons time and
we figured out a way to just do it
efficiently and cleanly but I get mad at
the antiquated nature of it and it just
makes me think I'm above this I'll just
come back to this tonight and I'll work
my way into it and it'll be fine
we're talking about blankets though so I
think the same thing apply of course I
think the same thing applies to blankets
if you're not gonna have guests because
I do agree that if you go to somebody's
house and you're like oh there's a
bundled up blanket on their couch yeah I
don't that means somebody drooled there
or worse and but if if it's just me and
my family I know who was on the couch
last night I was there we were watching
a movie together after we argued about
which one it would be I I don't make my
kid for ladies I don't I don't make them
do that but I do it because I like it
but I recognize it as a matter of taste
so it makes me happy but I don't it I
don't even force that on the kids
because I don't think that would be fair
so I I think that's the compromise I
admit that it's a matter of taste well
so as Michelle writers or husband right
because that's really what this comes
down to you're saying that her husband
is right I'm saying that I don't think
it's that I think it's a matter of taste
it's not a man you have to live together
and
you know you can imagine this situation
here I think that the situation is easy
if her husband believes that the
blankets need to be folded and put away
well he can do it that's what I'm saying
don't don't drag Michele into it yeah
yeah I do agree with that and I yeah oh
yeah Rek thanks for giving us these
these questions this topics and
conversation I learn lots of stuff
sounds like I might get to go surfing
again soon
a little wreck for you guys I mean I
could just wreck that documentary
because yeah if you're our age and you
and you were into basketball and want to
relive that Jordan glory days that's
great
I think I think if you care about sports
at all like Ronnie got the wreck the
last dance I'm not I've got at least one
more episode and like Phil Jackson is an
interesting person like we haven't
talked about this but I'm like man what
a what a someone who doesn't fit the
mold for his particular job scent is
such an interesting guy I wish they
would have talked more about him I want
to see a Phil Jackson documentary well
you know the guy who directed the last
dance also did a documentary on Andre
the Giant I've seen that one then yeah
that was good too but he's also done
like two or three other ones he just oh
he's because he's I think he did one on
the Pistons maybe he did one on another
another team I think that I could I
don't think it has to be the Chicago
Bulls I think I'm I think I'm really
opening myself up to sports
documentaries in general 34 30s all
right last dance that's our
recommendation hashtag your biscuits let
us know what you think about these
topics if that's blankets or reliving a
point in your life or all the stuff we
said about music let us have it will
speak at you next week to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right
the previous episode of your biscuits
click on the playlist to the left and
don't forget to click on the circular
icon to subscribe if you prefer to
listen to this podcast it's available on
all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]